so you also spoken Michael Knowles
um I think about the idea of what is a
woman I do can you speak broadly about
your conversations with the people you
disagree with
uh you know some of the cases it feels
like it's gone wrong the conversations
have gone wrong yeah yeah I mean I think
there's a couple different things and
I'm the first to tell you that
depending on who I'm talking to I go in
with a different attitude about how
quote seriously I'm taking it in the
sense of whether I think it's going to
be a deep policy discussion versus
whether it's going to be more of a
performance for an audience that is
expecting a certain thing and I think
there's different types of shows when I
was interviewed by this guy Jesse Lee
Peterson in Los Angeles it's very
different for example than when I'm
talking to Patrick Bett David just to
give two two examples I I think
the reason I stopped doing the Michael
Knowles show was the number of threats I
would get after the fact that's really
the reason I was glad to engage with him
to the extent that the interviews were
interesting and you know we could
organize it reasonably efficiently
um but the reason I stepped away was
sort of the aftermath but I did find him
to be someone who was abundantly clear
about his View and where he comes from
and while I could not possibly disagree
more with him in terms of politics and
culture and our backgrounds everything
is just so so different I found it easy
to engage in the conversation just
because of how upfront and clear he was
about what his beliefs were
but the number of threats yeah much yeah
it was just too much